hi there steve kaufman here today to
talk about language learning again
uh to exchange my views with uh those of
you out there who are interested in
learning languages
um today i want to talk about something
that i have mentioned before but i think
cannot be overstated
it's an extremely important
um part or should be an extremely
important part of our our language
learning strategy and that is the
importance of variety
and there are a number of reasons for
this first of all because to learn
anything our brains require a
combination of novelty
and repetition
so
that is always a part of my strategy
when i choose what kind of content i'm
going to listen to
um
but it's not just the novelty and
repetition that's good for our brains
it's the fact that when we have variety
it makes things more interesting and
keeping things interesting is also
extremely important in language learning
because that's what keeps you going it
leads to consistency it leads to staying
with it so you're achieving this sort of
freshness novelty because you're
changing the nature of your activity but
you're also and which therefore is
helping the brain learn but you're also
keeping it interesting and and you know
i often compare language learning to
sort of different fitness activities
so there's a concept in
in training that came up when i was a
youngster and was called fart lake
run it came from
the swedish and in swedish the word fart
means speed it doesn't mean
whatever it means in english and fartlek
means playing with speed so you'd go out
say jogging
but every so often you sprint and then
you go back to jogging so you're playing
with different speeds because
whatever you're doing whether it's the
brain or running if you kind of stay in
the same mode the whole time there is
sort of a declining efficiency
we talked about interleaving robert
bjork and his research on how
learning something leaving it a while
going back to something else coming back
to the first thing all of this helps you
in other words learning for getting
learning forgetting all of this helps
you to learn
so i noticed the reason i'm talking
about this is because i noticed that uh
in my arabic learning uh i had some i
had 10 online discussions with ibrahim
from egypt
and then i got a little bit tired of
struggling all the time
so i said i'll devote myself now to
uh
difficult content so i'm
fighting my way through these al jazeera
news articles that i import from the al
jazeera website into link and i go
through them and i'm looking up words
but there are fewer and fewer blue words
uh i'm now down to about 20 to 30
unknown words of course a lot of words
that i've met before i have no law i
have not yet learned but the whole
process gradually is one of more and
more words becoming familiar and then i
listen to the al jazeera podcast and of
course it's fun to listen to this
because it's lively and people are
talking and discussing and agreeing or
disagreeing
it's it's lively
it's a it's a
change from my many stories where it's
the same voice and there's a lot of
repetition and stuff so that's fun and
yet i don't really understand it
uh i'm now arranging to have some of
these transcribed by the way
so then i go back to my old mini stories
and lo and behold i understand them a
lot better it seems that they are now
spoken more slowly because i had that
the fast
audio from the podcast
where i i in fact was training my brain
to hear the words quite clearly even if
i don't know what the words mean
so then when i go back to my mini
stories not only do i hear the words
more clearly but i hear some of the
grammatical structures that this is a
third person plural or it's the it's a
female or it's a male or all these
things that i know about how the
language works but
i didn't always notice before when i was
listening to it but now that i have
exposed myself to faster material more
difficult material i go back to the
easier material and what do you know
it's easier than it was before so
what i wanted to emphasize and i've
mentioned it before but i think it's
it's it's worth stressing
vary
your activities of course focus on
things that are of interest to you
ideally but you may not be at a level as
this case with me in my arabic where i
can really make sense of the stuff that
is inherently interesting to me
so i do some of that
but then i go back to the easier stuff
and i had a few sessions
online talking with my tutor and so i
vary things i do the same when i go
through my review exercises on link i
will vary sometimes i'll have all five
the dictation the reverse flash card the
flash card the closed test the multiple
choice and sometimes i'll just do it
do two or three of them depending on my
mood so i'm varying it in many ways so i
just want to emphasize that in order to
keep yourself going keep the brain fresh
learn as effectively as possible
make sure you introduce as much variety
into your language learning as you can
so on that note i look forward to your
comments
[Music]
you